eine unfassbar grausame tat erschüttert
im mai 20 21 die welt von schlagerstar
der band monrose ein 51 jähriger mann
soll die cousine und die tante des
sängers mit mehreren kopfschüssen
ermordet haben heute beginnt am
landesgericht salzburg der prozess gegen
den mutmaßlichen doppelmörder bild kennt
die anklageschrift und auch seine dunkle
vergangenheit
es ist ein albtraum für die familie von
stefan mross privatdetektiv gottfried
erschoss in der nacht von 5 auf 6 mai
2021 helga b die cousine von tv
moderator stefan mross weil sie seine
zudringlichkeiten ablehnte als ingrid b
die tante von wars ihrer tochter in
deren haus in waltz in österreich zu
hilfe eilte wurde auch sie mit mehreren
schüssen aus einer glock 27 eiskalt
hingerichtet jetzt beginnt der prozess
gegen gottfried vor dem landesgericht
salzburg die überraschung laut der
anklageschrift die bild vorliegt muss
sich der brutale stalker auch wegen
zahlreicher weiterer verbrechen
verantworten die staatsanwaltschaft
wirft ihm neben zweifachen mord auch
einen versuchten mord vor angeklagt ist
der detektiv zudem wegen
körperverletzung gefährlicher drohung
fahrlässiger körperverletzung
tierquälerei betrügereien in mehreren
fällen besitz von verbotenen waffen
sowie stalking gottfried hatte sein
späteres opfer lkb beharrlich verfolgt
laut polizeibericht der ebenfalls bild
vorliegt hatte der jüngere bruder des
opfers in den monaten vor der tat
mehrfach die polizei um hilfe gebeten
vergeblich laut einem psychiatrischen
gutachten war gottfried von dem ruß
cousine besessen er sprach von ihr als
frau seines lebens dabei bestand kontakt
nur von dezember 2020 bis januar 2021
der arzt attestiert dem doppelmörder
eine kombinierte persönlichkeitsstörung
mit emotional instabilen dissozialen und
nazistisch sadistischen anteilen mit
seiner tat hat gottfried das glück der
moz familie für immer zerstört
unser bild reporter jörg völkerling ist
für uns vor ort vor dem landesgericht
salzburg jörg ein grausamer mord eines
stalkers was erwartest du heute von der
anklage
letztlich vor allen dingen an aufklärung
darüber was in den monaten vorher von
behördenseite unternommen wurde um
gottfried zu stoppen es gab also drei
anzeigen im jahr vor der schrecklichen
tat wiegen von meinem arbeitgeber der
sagte gottfried habe mit einer waffe
zwischen seine beine gezielt eine
nachbarin die in wegen nachstellung
angezeigt hat und dann natürlich auch
der bruder von helga b selbst der sich
im januar noch an die polizei wandte und
sagte gottfried stelle ihr beharrlich
nach seiner schwester bombardiere sie
mit sms und mehr das muss geklärt werden
warum dann nicht eingeschritten wurde
die staatsanwaltschaft sagt immer es gab
wechselseitigen kontakt zwischen lkw und
dem angeklagten das reiche nicht für
eine stalking anzeige und es wurden muss
auch aufgeklärt werden wie lange kannten
sich die beiden eigentlich geht das
gerücht dass helga b und gottfried wo
sich schon in den 90er jahren in einer
sauna und freilassing kennenlernten und
immer wieder lose kontakt hatten er
selbst bezeichnet sich als sein
dornröschen aber dass es offenbar eine
vollkommen romantisierte vorstellung von
einer beziehung york du verfolgst es
heute weiter für uns herzens auf dem
laufenden aus salzburg vielen dank für
den moment jörg völkerling
[Musik]